[Musique]
m
faisant le massif du mont-blanc offrait
aux touristes l'une des plus belles
excursions du monde entier
de chamonix le téléphérique le plus haut
d'europe les conduisait jusqu'à
l'aiguillé du midi à 3800 mètres et de
la leur faim jusqu en italie le survol
de la vallée blanche et du glacier du
géant
et voici que s'est produit le drame un
drame stupide toujours là qui était
exceptionnellement beau 87 personnes
avaient tenté les 30 cabines du
téléphérique pour le voyage de cinq
kilomètres au dessus du vide à 25
kilomètres à l'heure fac télécabine
emportait un maximum de quatre voyageurs
à la découverte de ce spectacle unique
et tout à coup l'un prévu l'incroyable
se produisait un avion de chasse
surgissait et sectionné le câble
tracteurs
des télécabines s'emballait c'était la
catastrophe
[Musique]
totalement décroché lé s'écraser 150
mètres plus bas où le riz témoigne
tristement aujourd'hui de la mort de
leurs six occupants les autres
télécabine restait suspendu entre ciel
et terre
les secours aussitôt s'organiser du côté
français comme du côté italien mais le
sauvetage n'était pas facile et malgré
l'intervention des hélicoptères
voyageurs allait passer une nuit
dramatique dans le froid et la peur
prisonniers du vide à 3500 mètres
d'altitude
l'aspirant guide gestion mollier devait
tenter lui de se tirer date tout seul en
utilisant le câble sectionné au long
duquel il cessa descendre à la force du
poignet une descente de 150 mètres au
bout de laquelle il arrive est épuisé
mais sains et saufs
l'envoi sera dure et 20h drame a fait
six victimes et l'on se dit que c'est
une espèce de miracle qu'il n'y en ait
pas eu 87
à la ménagère qui s'interroge sur le
prix des légumes faudra-t-il répondre
qu'il y a du chemin à parcourir depuis
le lieu de la récolte mais ce chemin
explique-t-il que le prix ait pu doubler
et plus entre le départ et l'arrivée
oui sans doute si l'on imagine que des
produits récoltés dans un département du
centre passe par exemple par les halles
de paris
[Musique]
si l'on imagine que d'un intermédiaire à
l'autre ces produits finissent par
reprendre le chemin d'un département
voisin de leur lieu d'origine
or il faut le dire peut-être circuit
n'est pas impossible alors on a vu les
producteurs bretons vendre eux-mêmes
leurs choux fleurs dans les rues de
paris simplification radicale certes du
circuit les impossibles à l'échelon
national
c'est donc de l'organisation des marchés
qu'il faut attendre une amélioration
véritable d'abord au stade de la
production c'est l'exemple du marché de
châteaurenard dont les haut parleurs
ouvre aux acheteurs la production de
toute une région avec contrôle constant
des cours
c'est encore l'exemple à lyon du nouveau
marché gare vaste installation qui avec
leurs seize hectares sont sans doute
actuellement parmi les plus importantes
d'europe qui est routier et qui est de
chemin de fer
[Musique]
bureau de poste
bureau de police et de douane
4h30 c'est l'heure du grand rush
contacts multiples producteurs de la
région acheteurs commissionnaires
détaillants producteurs expéditeurs
toutes les opérations commerciales ont
l'avantagé ici de bénéficier à chaque
instant de la connaissance des cours
donnés par le chef des ventes et c'est
en définitive par une diminution de prix
de revient que se traduit l'effet d'un
tel marché
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le marché de montlhéry va plus loin
encore la vente sur échantillons qui s'y
pratique élimine tout manutention seuls
les échantillons entrent dans la salle
où sous les yeux des acheteurs installés
sur les gradins un cadran propose les
enchères des croissants
une simple pression sur un bouton arrête
la vente au prix a dit c'est une
économie de 25 % qui serait réalisée
réalisation des grands marchés 25% dont
devraient bénéficier producteurs et
consommateurs
sommes-nous sur le point de voir révéler
la vie inconnue des étrusques entre
cerveteri et tarpinian l'équipe du
professeur carlo de lerici grâce à ces
méthodes de détection se propose de
détecter et de visiter des milliers de
tom jusqu'ici ignoré le professeur de
lerici a tout simplement imaginer
d'utiliser pour la recherche
archéologique le matériel de forage
utilisé pour les recherches minières une
performeuse permet d'arriver au vide
d'une chambre funèbre un périscope point
sa place et manipulé depuis la surface
permet une investigation visuel
suffisantes pour juger de l'intérêt
historique et artistique du tombeau
grâce à cette méthode pendant les cinq
dernières années le professeur de lerici
à inventorier 2500 tomba chambre
mortuaire découvert 20 tombe à peinture
et réunit plus de 6000 pièces
artistiques
ainsi en appliquant à l'archéologie les
moyens géophysique réservé jusqu'ici à
la prospection industriels le savant
italien aura t'il rendu un immense
service à la recherche archéologique
grâce à ses moyens les fouilleurs
peuvent choisir à bon escient la tombe
riche d'enseignements qui les paiera de
leur peine au lieu de perdre beaucoup de
temps tâtonnements et en efforts
inutiles muette depuis 2500 ans la
civilisation étrusque va-t-elle enfin
parler
[Musique]
belgrade capitale des pays non engagé
selon la formule consacrée le maréchal
tito a reçu ce qu'arnaud président de la
république indonésienne modibo keita
président du mali hassan ii roi du maroc
en tout 24 délégations réunies pour
affirmer la position du troisième bloc
[Musique]
étaient présents le colonel nasser l'un
des leaders de cette conférence au
sommet l'évêque macario ce directeur de
conscience de la république de chypre et
le président bourguiba dont c'était
l'apparition dans ce tiers mais si la
conférence n'a pas condamné comme on s'y
attendait la surprise nucléaire venus de
moscou il n'en est pas moins vrai que le
geste de l'urss a suscité dans son
ensemble les regrets de la conférence
des neutraliste
en france est allée rendu rss est
aujourd'hui très facile l'urss est en
effet à septembre à la porte de
versailles sous la forme d'une
exposition compte inaugurer un ministre
soviétique me suis patriote chef et un
ministre français monsieur janet
si l'image que veut donner d'elle-même
l'urss comportent un certain décor de la
vie aujourd'hui très général elle se
singularise en montant en épingle ses
réalisations cosmique les capsules de
gagarine et de titoff et les spoutniks
de toutes sortes y tiennent bien entendu
la place d'honneur mais à côté de cette
démonstration de puissance l'exposition
soviétique de paris a voulu aussi faire
impression par d'autres moyens et
l'offensive de charme a été menée
tambour battant par la mode moscovite
[Musique]
on ne s'improvise pas pirates même au
cinéma encore faut-il savoir un tant
soit peu manier l'épée le sabre évolué
avec le maximum d un son milieu des plus
rudes qu'orateur c'est la raison qui a
amené les vedettes d'une superproduction
de la meilleure tradition à se frotter
aux cascadeurs italiens eux qui n'ignore
rien des secrets du métier
il reste que se laisser tomber d'autres
1 m même quand le point de chute a été
consciencieusement rembourrés n'est pas
à proprement parler un exercice de tout
repos
[Musique]